مهرجان انطلق في العاصمه العمانيه في 19
يناير ومستمر لاربعه فبراير ومليان
فعاليات امس وفي احدى العاب المهرجان
المقامه في مركز عمان للمعارض والمؤتمرات
وقع حادث واتنشر له مقطع مرعب بصراحه
[موسيقى]
المقطع انتشر والناس بدات الدوله بتسال
ايش صار وكيف ومين الضحايا وعددهم وطبعا
مثل العاده الاشاعات كمان بدات وتضاربت
الاخبار والواحد ما اعرف ايش الصح من
الغلط بلديه مسقط فورا في سلسله بيانات
وضحت الموضوع اولا نشرت بيان قالت فيه ان
تاسف للحادث اللي وقع واعلنت انها بتحقق
فيه الاسباب وبتقيم الاضرار اناشده الناس
استقصاء المعلومات من المصادر الرسميه
ثاني قالت بلديه مسقط انه الاصابات
بليغه لكن رجعت في بيان الثالث
المستشفى وفي حالتين فقط
حالتهم وتم تحويلهم لاجراء المزيد من
الفحوصات الدفاع المدني العماني هو كمان
اصغر بيان عن التعامل فرق مع الحادث وكشف
انه الاصابات لسبعه اطفال سيده وان تراوحد
بين المتوسطه والخفيفه